There's a lot going on in Star Wars Episode
IX, which means that some characters were
bound to fall by the wayside as others took
the lead in the closing chapter of the saga.
Here are several characters with relatively
small roles in The Rise of Skywalker, along
with why each one ended up with such limited
screen time.
The Force Awakens introduced viewers to an
older, wiser Leia Organa, now a general leading
the Resistance against the First Order.
Leia continued in that role in The Last Jedi,
but actress Carrie Fisher sadly and suddenly
died in 2016 after completing work on that
film.
Director J.J. Abrams opted to use several
minutes of Leia footage left over from The
Force Awakens for The Rise of Skywalker, so
Leia is present throughout most of the film
as the leader of the Resistance.
But the limited Fisher footage meant that
she was often shown simply observing and reacting
to other characters.
The dialogue scenes she does have are short,
and with the help of movie magic, Abrams engineered
a somber, meaningful death scene for her character.
Lots of fan favorite characters from the original
trilogy, including Han Solo, Leia Organa,
and Luke Skywalker, returned in The Force
Awakens.
But what about Han's old pal and the suavest
dude in the galaxy, Lando Calrissian?
Lando didn't make his return until The Rise
of Skywalker, and it's easy to see why.
With both Han Solo and Luke Skywalker dead,
and Leia Organa pulling limited duty, the
film needed another Rebel legend to turn to.
In the end, though, that's pretty much all
Lando is there for.
An intended subplot about Lando meeting his
long-lost daughter was reportedly cut out
of the film, leaving him to just look cool,
saying a few catchy lines, and be an inspirational
figure for the younger heroes.
When it was announced that Mark Hamill would
return to reprise the role of Luke Skywalker
for The Force Awakens, fans were excited,
but then learned he only appeared onscreen
in the final scene.
The Last Jedi gave Luke a lot to do, but it
presented a divisive version of Luke Skywalker,
capping things off with the character's redemptive
death.
Fans were excited to find out Hamill would
be back for The Rise of Skywalker, but surely
he couldn't do that much as a Force ghost,
right?
He does appear a key moment in the story,
when Rey is doubting herself and contemplating
a self-exile similar to Luke's own.
He dispenses some wisdom then shuffles back
off into the afterlife.
After that, he does some voiceover, and that's
the entirety of his role.
In The Last Jedi, one of the most important
new characters was Rose Tico, a Resistance
mechanic who ran into Finn and struck up a
friendship that led to a mission and even
a hint of romance.
Rose shows back up in Rise as a mainstay of
the Resistance.
Unfortunately, that role apparently also came
at the cost of her screen time.
As Rey, Finn, and Poe head out for their mission
early in the film, Rose explains that she
can't come because Leia has asked her to stay
behind.
She then disappears for much of the rest of
the film before fighting in the Battle of
Exegol.
According to co-writer Chris Terrio, Rose's
role in the film was initially beefier, but
had to be cut down because of special effects
issues.
He told AwardsDaily,
“We wanted Rose to be the anchor at the
rebel base who was with Leia...As the process
evolved, a few scenes we'd written with Rose
and Leia turned out to not meet the standard
of photorealism that we'd hoped for.
Those scenes unfortunately fell out of the
film.”
Maz Kanata's presence in The Force Awakens
raised a number of questions about why the
cantina owner and former smuggler knew so
much about the Force and how she had possession
of Luke Skywalker's lightsaber.
Those questions never really got answered.
After a brief appearance in The Last Jedi...
"Maz, what is happening?"
"Union dispute.
You do not want to hear about it."
Maz appears at Resistance base in The Rise
of Skywalker, where she stays for pretty much
the entire movie without really contributing
much to the plot.
She functions almost as a Greek chorus, using
her wisdom and knowledge of the Force to help
give the audience some context for Leia's
final struggle, then popping up during the
final celebration to give Chewbacca a medal.
When Finn, Poe, and Rey make it to the Endor
system, they come across a group of warriors
who agree to help them get to the debris of
the second Death Star to find what they're
looking for.
These warriors are later revealed to be deserter
stormtroopers who've made a life for themselves,
stripping their old First Order ship for parts
to get by.
Their leader, Jannah, has a conversation with
Finn about the shared aspects of their pasts.
Jannah's a fascinating character with a lot
of potential depth, but she doesn't get a
really big chunk of screentime.
She gets early moments on Endor establishing
who she is, then hangs around with Finn throughout
the final battle, but we don't really learn
what her real desires are other than to fight
the First Order.
There's a hint of what she does next in a
very ambiguous scene with Lando at the end
of the film, a likely holdover from the cut
subplot where she was meant to be Lando's
daughter.
When Finn, Poe, and Rey head out for their
mission to find Palpatine, the gang takes
C-3PO and BB-8 along for the trip, but leave
R2-D2 behind at the Resistance base.
Artoo is thus relatively quiet until he flies
into battle with Poe at the end of the film.
Why leave Artoo, arguably the most iconic
and beloved droid in the franchise, back at
the base for much of the film?
Well, in many ways Artoo has always felt like
Luke Skywalker's droid, and with Luke out
of the picture for so much of the sequel trilogy,
Artoo doesn't always fit.
As it turns out, Rise of Skywalker is much
more of a showcase for Threepio's place in
Star Wars lore.
And considering BB-8 has become the unofficial
mascot of the sequel trilogy, the filmmakers
likely chose to give a little more screentime
to that little toyetic ball droid to close
out the series.
"Where do you come from?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Star Wars
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.